dans le sud de l'Ukraine près d'Odessa
les moissonneuses batteuses fonctionnent
sans interruption la récolte de blé
commençait il y a quelques semaines bat
son plein comme si de rien n'était
pourtant l'exportation des céréales
n'est plus garantie l'accord entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine avec la médiation de
la Turquie expire ce lundi soir il y a
quelques jours Moscou déploré qu'aucune
demande russe n'avait été prise en
compte
je n'ai entendu aucune nouvelle
proposition
l'accord conclut il y a un an est déjà
renouvelé deux fois a permis de sortir
près de 33 millions de tonnes de
céréales des portes Ukrainiens malgré la
guerre
des dents réseaux essentiels notamment
pour éviter des famines dans des pays
africains et une envolée des prix sur le
marché mondial
exhorte la Russie à renouveler le texte
et cinq choses il est essentiel
d'étendre le développer l'initiative sur
les céréales de la mer Noire à laquelle
la Russie menace de mettre fin une fois
de plus le 18 juillet si Moscou mais sa
menace exécution les pays en
développement et compris dans la région
paieront le prix y compris au sens
propre avec des prêts alimentaires plus
élevés et une plus grande pénurie
alimentaire
Moscou de son côté affirme que le non
renouvellement de la corne signifierait
pas l'abandon de l'Afrique
Vladimir Poutine s'était dit prêt au
mois de mars à livrer gratuitement les
pays les plus nécessiteux parmi lesquels
le Soudan la Somalie ou encore
l'Éthiopie le président russe cherche
ainsi à courtiser de nouveaux
partenaires il organise d'ailleurs le
sommet Afrique Russie à
Saint-Pétersbourg la semaine prochaine
après une première édition il y a 4 ans
un sommet où les questions de sécurité
alimentaire seront très largement
abordés